Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going to
explain a thriller drama film called “Monolith.”
Spoilers ahead! Watch out and take care!
The movie begins with an advertisement for a
futuristic car brand named Monolith. The presenter
from the advertisement states that the car is
awarded as the safest car in the world and has
a number of unique safety features. He claims
that the car is extremely modern and has several
features like unbreakable glass, strong tires,
rigid body, and many more to keep its riders
safe from every possible theft and damage.
An AI-connected smartphone app is used to control
all the features while being inside the car.
A virtual assistant called Lilith helps to
interact with the user interface of the car.
In the next scene, we can see a mother
carrying her kid inside the same AI car
to his granny’s home. While talking
to the AI assistant, Lilith,
we get to know that the mother’s name is Sandra
and her 2-year-old son is David. Her husband,
Carl, is a pilot who could not join
them due to his busy schedule. The
car is so advanced that it can even detect the
weight of the passengers inside the vehicle.
Later, Carl calls them and informs that he is
at the central airport after his duty and misses
them a lot. Just then, someone knocks on the door
and Carl says his goodbye and leaves. Meanwhile,
David starts becoming fussy so Sandra hands
him her smartphone to keep him occupied.
After some time, Sandra takes a halt at a gas
station on the side of the road. She then takes
David inside the washroom and changes his diapers
while some girls are seen giggling. The gas
station also has a supermarket where Sandra buys
her son his favorite snacks. While paying at the
counter, Sandra notices someone trying to break
into her car outside. Instead of being worried,
she just takes out her smartphone and locks
the vehicle using the smart app. As Sandra is
busy inspecting the situation, she doesn’t even
notice that David has been separated from her.
After she realizes that David is lost, she screams
and searches for him around the supermarket.
She rushes outside and even calls a stranger
assuming that David is with him. She seems to
be totally freaked out until she finds David with
the same three ladies whom she met earlier at the
washroom. Sandra immediately puts David into
her car and activates the vault mode feature.
This disengages her from what's happening outside
and she finally breathes a sigh of relief.
After leaving the gas station, Sandra still
has a long distance to drive until they reach
her mother-in-law’s house. Due to the long
ride, Sandra feels bored and decides to call
her childhood friend, Jessa to check on her. Jessa
receives the call and informs her that she is near
the central airport at a hotel. She even tells
Jessa that she has been staying at the hotel with
Carl. Sandra is devastated at the revelation of
her friend having an affair with her husband.
She becomes so frustrated that she does not even
bother to enter her mother-in-law’s house after
reaching the entrance. She continues
calling Carl but he doesn’t pick up
and pretends to be busy. Fed up with the
lies, Sandra decides to take matters into
her own hands and hence sets her journey to find
Carl at the central airport in Los Angeles.
On her way, a board shows that the distance to Los
Angeles is about 320 miles. After a while, Lilith,
the smart AI, mentions that a serious accident
has taken place on the main highway, which will
slow them down. She then suggests Sandra take the
bypass road, which will save them a lot of time.
However, the AI also mentions that the route
is deserted and barely has any passengers.
Sandra, who is adamant on confronting
her husband, does not think twice
and takes the alternative route.
Later, it gets dark and Sandra starts
to feel difficulty in driving the car. The fog on
the way also intensifies, which affects her vision
of the road in front. On her way, she finds no
human settlements or any other vehicles. However,
she finds an electrical substation located in the
middle of nowhere. She glances over the place but
soon drives away. The place is so deserted that
the only beings present there are wild animals.
Suddenly, a nervous Sandra loses her focus and
crashes into a deer which was trying to cross
the road. Because of the collision,
David starts crying and like always,
Sandra gives her smartphone to calm him down. She
then immediately gets out to check on the animal
but it appears to be almost dead.The deer is stuck
below the front part of the car and because of it,
Sandra is unable to move her car ahead. As
Sandra is trying to figure out the situation,
she forgets that she has left David alone in
the car. Meanwhile, as David is playing with
the cellphone, he accidentally opens the
AI car app. He moves his finger around the
opened app and without Sandra’s notice,
activates the Vault feature of the car.
This feature protects the passengers inside
from all kinds of disturbances and danger.
Sandra realizes the gravity of the
situation and tries her best to
open the door but it's already too late.
As Sandra is locked outside the car,
she tries her best to make the 2 year old
David switch off the vault mode but he doesn’t
understand a word and simply keeps on playing
with the phone. Later, Sandra panics and starts
shouting at the little kid, which startles him,
and he drops the smartphone under his seat.
Here, Sandra gets to know that the Monolith car’s
features are not just an advertisement but it also
performs in reality. Even when Sandra tries to
break the glass with a rock, not a single scratch
can be seen on the window glass. Seeing all her
efforts go in vain, Sandra decides to seek other
options. She begins walking back to the electrical
substation which she noticed before.
After some walking, she reaches the station, jumps
over the fence and cries out for help. However,
she gets no response and the station seems to
be empty with no workers present at the moment.
After this, Sandra enters one of the rooms and
finds some necessary items inside. She takes
a flashlight to use at night and a big wrench
to help her break the glass of the locked car.
Just as she leaves the substation, she
notices a wild animal following her.
As Sandra rushes back, a coyote attacks her so
she climbs onto the roof of the car. Despite
her best efforts to scare off the animal, it
remains unphased. In a last ditch attempt,
Sandra starts banging the car with the wrench
and an alarm starts blaring, which finally makes
the coyote retreat. Just then, Sandra notices
David having difficulties in breathing. Despite
the situation, she manages to calm David and he
finally starts breathing and soon falls asleep.
After a bit of thinking, Sandra too becomes tired
and falls asleep on the bonnet of the car.
The next day, Sandra wakes up
when the sun is already bright.
She then immediately rushes to check David’s
condition inside the car. She finds David weak
and feeble because of his hungry stomach and
dehydration. One of the features of the car also
displays the temperature of the surroundings
which appears to be increasing slowly. The
condition is a curse to Sandra as the place is
completely isolated with no humans around.
Sandra then decides to seek help and follows
the road. Despite being severely dehydrated,
she proceeds to walk the long journey. She
also knows the risks of leaving David alone
in the overheated car but she has no
choice but to seek help. Fortunately,
she comes across a river where she drinks and
cleans herself. After gaining some respite,
she continues her journey and encounters steep
hills along the path. After walking several miles,
Sandra finally comes across an old airfield, where
she discovers a jet. Meanwhile, the temperature
inside the Monolith car rises up, causing it to
instantly start the emergency cooling fan.
After reaching the abandoned jet, Sandra enters
inside and discovers some alcoholic drinks,
a gallon of gasoline, a lighter
and a pair of spare airplane tires.
She consumes some alcohol and immediately gathers
the necessary items. After that, Sandra uses the
gasoline to burn the two tires, in hopes of
attracting help. She then takes the gallon
and fills it with the river water. Slowly, Sandra
walks back to the place where she left David.
In the next scene, Sandra hurries to the car and
finds David all weak and turning red. She tries
calling him out, but David does not answer or
move. The temperature inside the car has increased
significantly and the emergency cooling fans have
become ineffective. Seeing the state of her son,
Sandra immediately climbs the roof and
pours the water she brought from the river,
but all her efforts go into vain. Thinking that
her child will have to die inside the high-tech
vehicle, she again starts to hit the car window
with the wrench but it just wastes her energy.
Later, Sandra tries to light a fire outside
the car in hopes that the censors will detect
the smoke and open the windows, but none of this
happens. Instead, the emergency cooling fans stop
running to prevent the smoke from entering
inside. Fatigued, Sandra falls to the ground
and gets a vision of her and Carl visiting the
same accident place after a year. There, she
realizes her mistakes and still blames Carl for
David’s death. After some time, she wakes up to
some noise and finds it all to be her dream.
To make the situation worse, the coyote from
last night again appears in front of her. Sandra
decides to hide from it and tries to climb on the
roof of the car. But as the car’s temperature
is extremely high, she can’t stay there and
instead slides below the car. There, the coyote
bites her leg and this is when Sandra realizes
that it is the deer that the coyote is after.
As soon as the coyote drags the deer out,
the car starts rolling backwards. The
deer was the reason which had held the
car in the position. Sandra immediately gets
out from under the car and tries to stop it
from sliding backwards. Despite her best efforts,
the car still continues to roll backwards, edging
closer to a fall. However, a small chunk of
rock obstructs the car and it finally stops.
As Sandra stares from the cliff, she remembers
the cartoon she saw earlier at the gas station,
where the diamond was obtained after the safe
was broken. She then thinks of pushing the car
down to unlock the doors. Sandra is well
aware of the fact that her plans might
have consequences but she is left with no
other choice and decides to go with it.
She grabs the wrench and starts breaking
the rock which was obstructing the
tire. After successfully removing the rock,
Sandra purposely pushes the car down the cliff
with David still inside the car.
As the car is thrown in the air,
its inbuilt AI starts to function and immediately
realizes that the car is falling from a height.
The features of the car get to work and shift
its balance, studying the gravitational pressure
to fall upright, without causing any harm to
David. Since the car was designed to deactivate
the vault mode at the time of an accident to let
the rescuers come in, the doors finally open.
As soon as the car strikes the ground,
Sandra climbs down the cliff and approaches
the car. Despite the devastating fall, the car
appears as if someone just placed it there.
Finding the locked door open, Sandra
hurriedly takes David out of the car
and opens his clothes to help him cool down.
Seeing David's weak health condition,
Sandra resolves to get out of the place as soon as
possible. Before Sandra gets in the car to drive,
the whole system gets restarted. With the help of
Lilith, Sandra sets the car into extreme offroad
mode and starts climbing the cliff in front
of her. The car appears to be made for very
extreme conditions and easily gets past the steep
cliff. Miraculously, Sandra reaches the offroad
she chose and heads towards the hospital.
In the last scene of the movie, we see Sandra
and David arriving at the hospital. David is
kept on the hospital bed beside Sandra and is
connected with multiple tubes. Sandra seems
worried about David until he opens his eyes
and calls her “Mommy” for the first
time. The movie ends as Sandra gets
delighted at her son calling her out.
Subscribe for more videos like this, turn
on the notification, and leave a like to help
the channel out. Thank You for watching.